now i know there are guys out there  thinking  international women's day why don't we  have an international men's day  god bless you twitter well you're in  luck because you do it's actually on  november 19th fun fact november 19th is  also  international toilet day  now i'm not i'm not saying men are  toilets but  both holidays are mostly catered towards  a bunch of white johns  oh my god lord save me deliver me from  this trial white john's consider this  there were a bunch of jokes that didn't  make it to air they actually threw out  jokes because they were worse than that  maybe there's a brilliant writer in that  room probably a man let's be honest no  offense could be the second coming of  richard pryor in that room  writing material and maybe her sense of  humor is so bad that she throws those  out the brilliant material she i don't  like that white john's though that is  killer